the Game Developers Conference GDC is on
right here in San Francisco next week
and we were happy to be joining mr.
Simon Carlos let's sir how are you you
must be super not busy at the moment
right yes a few things going on but I
thought I'd special time to come out
with you guys just for a few minutes
considering your offices but like a
block and a half down the street yeah I
got here like an hour and a half early
because I got very excited then I was
like I just walked to the game so
obvious like two blocks all right so
there you go one of the things about GDC
that I find funny after sort of joining
the games price was that for years and
years I used to watch the awards and the
IGF awards and GDC Awards on gamespot
and see all the news that came out of it
but it's like it's one of the most
interesting awards that's on but I know
for people who are sort of outside of
the industry of don't actually attend
it's kind of an unknown so like what is
the GDC awards for folks who maybe
aren't familiar with sure yeah I mean in
that case um in East Coast GD c stands
for the game developers choice awards
and you know and we're obviously one of
the one of the few Awards out there that
was really voted entirely by the
community so so and that's to say our
community of game developers so so so we
spend a lot of time picking about a
thousand people from the industry and
they end up voting every year on the
best titles and the best thing about it
is it's actually in the same evening as
independent games first of all so you
get two awards for the price of one and
we get through them both in under two
hours most of the time yeah which is
reasonably impressive since Helms the
Oscars nowadays like yeah three and a
half absolutely miss mr. Schaffer is
reprising his his role as the MC MC of
the GDC Awards yeah that's what I'm Tim
Schafer was back he does he does every
other year yeah it seems like it because
it turns out he's running a game company
also and the family has to work on that
and needless to say he's not written one
word of his script so far oh really yeah
yeah and he's probably not watching but
he's renowned actually and notorious for
that reason i towing us procrastinator
yes and actually one year he managed to
make a flash game about not writing the
script oh really if you go look online
you'll find someone that will find our
cover this is flash game which he did
with with a bunch of people and it's all
about how he hasn't written the script
yet and he genuinely sent us that with a
week to go nice and he was like guys
just a rock
I haven't been the word but I've done
this flash adventure game about not
writing a word has that nathan fellow
kaffee made any flash game this year
he's hosting the IGF Awards I'm night
Nathan actually has got those draft of
the script nice so yeah so Nathan Vella
hosting the independent games festival
from from Cathy of super time force Fame
yeah yeah and we're really excited he he
actually host it last year and he's a
really good host and again we try as
much as possible to get people from the
game development agency hosting because
like you know we don't have anything
against other words that have you know
shall we say more polished host
sometimes but we really like the genuine
hosts who are kind of kind of goofing
off and I guess that's the thing with
GDC is that it's a it's a conference for
game developers so of course you should
have a it's it's very much a sort of uh
I guess must be really interesting for
people who work tirelessly in various
parts of the world to finally have a
week to come together and share ideas
and share experiences what's the sort of
main focus for people who attends the
conference itself well it's interesting
because you're right and one of the good
things about Judy see is there's so many
people know those who are like Indies
and working solo or working in small
groups and it's so great for them all
all to come Sam Cisco and get a chance
to hang out because they you know they
often don't get to see the people that
they talked to on social media all year
no you know I think yeah I mean you know
there's always a bunch of focuses around
the show and what we've done is we've
gradually built up like a whole bunch of
kind of summits within the main show so
for example we have a summit just about
India member summit about free to play
we have something about getting
narrative only but actually virtually
this year we have some new summits and
and we have for the first time in
eSports summit no answers kind of you
know each boss it's not necessarily a
novel idea but we've kind of made it a
rule we don't necessarily produce a
summit like the very first opportunity
jerk reaction yeah otherwise we would
have had you know like a 3d TV somewhere
right yeah that's not the best idea so
so so we try and time it so with
somewhere you know i mean the hype curve
kicks in there but at some point you
realize actually there's something
ongoing here that will benefit everyone
and i think actually we actually the
servo amongst our developers and we
found that although only about fifteen
percent of our audience are
are currently working on in the eSports
again they consider any sport I think
about eighty-five percent of them think
it's going to be a big thing in the
future and also as a lot of lessons that
regular developers can learn from what's
going on eSports which is you know
there's just there's just so many good
learnings for house stuff displays on on
streaming you know streaming is really
important how multiplayer competition
works so you know we have a bunch of
interesting talks that's on Tuesday
where we have a whole day whole day
program related to that and we have for
example the lead lead design of League
of Legends is going to be interviewed by
Frank Lance we have a talk on on
counter-strike go modding we have a talk
on starcraft 2 interface modding we have
a talk on on the role of the role of
women in these sports and yeah there's a
whole bunch of interesting stuff there
so I think that's going to be good
there's so much going on at GDC I know
here on gamespot we're going to be
streaming the the awards the IGF awards
and a few select panel a few select
panels as well I'll here actually there
they are on screen right now and in
clear and we also will have a recording
of John Carmack ski know which might run
on just a little bit longer than he's
already gone yeah so so yes I john
cornett so John Carmack is speaking on
Wednesday and it's kind of a featured
talk after the after hour flash forward
which which kicks off a day and we left
me a little time in to lunch because
he's already said in this talk
description he intends to go until
someone pulls me offstage with a light
like a hook yeah so that's pretty much
what we're expecting but yeah yeah it's
it's difficult in GDC is just such a
great time for developers to learn a lot
about the industry and I think for us
and for our readers and it's really
interesting to get that inside look to
learn about a lot of things that usually
are kind of hidden from us but there's
also a lot of news especially recently
like you know people are doing some
reveals and hardware reveal software
reveals do you guys try to push back on
that at all to make sure that it stays
focused on the developers yeah that's an
interesting question because we have had
in the past we have had keynotes to the
show and although you know i would say
john carmack is like a big talk we
officially kind of have stayed away from
from keynotes recently because there's
been a thing in the past where people
have been tempted to announce things
to the world actually there's a bunch of
developers in front of them yeah you
know sir and it's difficult because you
know whilst you might want to talk about
you know particular things such as XNA
that's very relevant to developers
there's a bunch of other stuff you also
want to get out about about your
platform so you know so it's I think
we've decided this like we're really
happy with for people to make
announcements like around the show and
obviously we're super excited that you
know valve seems to be announcing things
and we do have we'd ever talks on this
type of thing but I think you know we
definitely think that III is the place
for platform holders and large
publishers to be making kind of the
here's our lineup kind of thing and I
think what we're seeing with Judy see is
people are announcing new hardware at
the show and they are showing a bunch of
games about the show often kind of you
know in the peripheral area we do have
also quite a lot of play ball games
around our show floor but they're much
more kind of games that are trying to
get some you know some interest with
publish your story under shopping the
man yeah I mean yeah there's no shortage
of game conferences now for people to
announce though if they if they so want
to but like you said perhaps one of the
most interesting things about the
announcements we're hopefully going to
be seeing between as valve yesterday
showing off their their steam universe
thing or like talking about it being at
GDC if V or is actually going to be
something that tangibly works then
surely the company's several of which
seem to be at GDC shopping around need
to sell it to developers before
consumers will get the hook on it what
do you think about all the different
figure stuff that seems to be that's
going to be available at GDC you next
week yeah I think it's fascinating
because it really has been you know the
VR Tech has now been available to
developers for a little while so we're
starting to see games they're starting
to look pretty good you know we have
games like a drift which is which is the
game a divorce working on and we have a
game called classroom aquatic that I'm
kind of a fan of where you're the title
yeah you're like a dolphin and you have
to cheat on a multiple choice test okay
and you're in like an old school
classroom and the teacher is like a
diver and you have to avoid the teacher
noticing and so I still have a
movement-based awk it's pretty bizarre
it's only available arc
yeah but it actually speaks that if
actually speaks to the fact that you
know some of the use of interface issues
on the are just completely different ya
like like like like the fact is if
you're moving your head and your
character when quotes is moving that's
such a different feel such a different
gameplay field to most other you know
games yeah they're going to alien
isolation was a completely different
experience when you had the rift on and
then also like games like what it said
work together or everyone explodes or
shut up right oh yeah keep talking keep
talking i took a bit opposite of what i
was thinking where you're literally got
your hands in here in your g you're just
interacting with like with visuals yeah
and it seems like this is we've been
talking about you're like it's a it's a
massive news attraction on the side like
people are really interested in it what
do you hope comes out of vor GDC this
year do you think is they're worried
that if there's like three or four
different platform holders who are like
making their own little individual thing
that it'll just fragment that space up
too much and consumers won't get the
best yeah I mean I think the biggest
issue with peripherals is always
fragmentation and getting to a big
install base so I definitely think the
lid is a concern that if you have too
many systems and not one unified
standard then maybe they may be there
will be an issue but I think that's a
little bit being alleviated nowadays by
game engines light unity and unreal
because basically if you are a developer
then then you've got to know that unity
is going to help help you make sure
you're going to be on these platforms
fairly easily or unreal or any other
game engine so if you're building in one
of those engines it should be much
easier to port to all the systems and
that didn't used to be the case and
that's why you would see a lot of you
know a bunch of conversions coming up
very late after yeah but I mean that's
not the only thing but yeah I mean I
think it really I think one thing that
did people didn't appreciate about VR is
I do think that you know in many cases
conventional console games don't work
very well in VR you needed just a whole
different kind of game play experience
and I think wonder sometimes with that
game play experience is going to be
completely accessible to the mainstream
who are used to like ultra fast ultra
kind of action based games because you
can only whip your head around so
quickly well you know when your when
your envy up I think there's going to be
a bunch of really interesting
experiences and I think the fact that
valve is supporting it
you know so strongly or haven't quite
worked out how yet but you know the fact
that valve will have something and
certainly sony has something an oculus
has something and the certainly nvidia
seems to be making announcements sharon
has been some rumors that that that's we
are related as well although that hasn't
been confirmed yeah there's starting to
be a few platforms out there yeah a lot
of people are interested in it for sure
Justin I was going to say you know there
are so just so many panels in so much
going on and I know that you're gonna be
ridiculously busy during the week but is
there anything that you're already like
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna not be able
to do any other work I'm gonna go to
this panel i really want to check this
out guys I'm gonna I'm not gonna be able
to work during that time I really want
to see you know that's a really good
question i think i think what i really
enjoy the classic game post-mortems we
have you know every year we've started
that for 25th anniversary which was I
think three or four years ago so in
silence so now we've had maybe 16 to 20
of these classic post-mortems and all
available for free streaming on our on
our GDC vault website by the way and I
think number them are archived on them
as well so yeah and then actually this
year we have we start control is one of
the ones we have which is which is
obviously a real classic strategy title
we have yars revenge as well which is
very early Atari 2600 game but I'm
particularly excited about that because
Howard Scott Warshaw is the guy who made
that and he also famously made ET next
an exact fit which he made in six weeks
I'm sure you and I was talking about
that yeah it is like you know anything
obviously that we didn't make him do a
whole hour on his head but having a
little cruel but he but he did say
during that classic post-mortem he's
going to talk about he's going to talk a
little bit about the experience of
making making ET and all those available
on the GDC for can anyone access yes so
we don't quite do it in real time
because because we're recording so many
talks at the same time but I would say
like maybe one to two weeks after the
show you'll be able to see all of the
classic post-mortems and we also have
the Atari 2600 game adventure which was
the first famously the first game every
time an easter egg in it and and so I'm
excited about that just because you know
honestly some of these some of these
guys are getting a little bit older is
important that they talk about the games
because at some point they aren't going
to be around and there's going to be a
bunch of questions that we we wish we
wish would have asked them yeah
I made the game so I think doing doing
good stuff forgetting history it's good
i'm also quite involved in the indie
game summit and we've managed to pull in
some real interesting talks i'm a big
fan of 80 days the other iphone game and
it's actually yeah just our plane that
last week passed it's it's it's an
awesome game and actually there's a
there's a couple of talks of the show
and there's one by the vitae make giant
who's going to be talking about you know
that the writing for that game which i
think is really interesting you know
there's this kind of you know the
steampunk elements to it but there's a
little bit of kind of like romance in
here and all kinds of kind of
interesting things i think you know i
think i think games like that a really
cool and i'm pleased i think especially
with my gaming taste nowadays i like
playing kind of you know fairly fairly
Swift fairly swift repeat kind of games
so although some of that is twitch like
stuff like geometry wars i also like
playing 80 days because you can get
through it you know decent amount of
time you can replay it there's a lot of
replayability so you know i was gonna I
think there was a fear a few years back
that like mobile gaming was just kind of
take over everything in that hasn't been
the case at all yeah and it's actually
and the good thing about where mobile is
gone at this point is there's a bunch of
really interesting games in around kind
of the five dollar price point I think
anyone who's played games for a long
time can still get very excited about
it's just a question sometimes of
finding those gang switch yeah I think
it's difficult we're hopefully folks
like it's like you can help out with
that well I thought last year was a
great example of some fantastic games
sort of popping up where I feel like in
previous years perhaps it was it was
more difficult to find real quality
games like between God it fits so much
desert golf over the last couple of you
know like an 80 days as well of course
Monument Valley is well another
fantastic game which which has just been
so popular between such a bunch of
different ages as well revisiting old
for like keeping that that endless
runner keeping it new and fresh it is is
something I'm surprised that people keep
doing of Alto a game I recently started
playing Crossy Road we have such simple
ideas dahmer closes oh you show up at
cross you off for like two weeks and
then I ended up getting in a pack size
yeah just tap top top top top it off me
for a dollar every two minutes though
which is something I really do not want
to have any more
in games yes the best the best advice I
think the good side is you know you're
starting to see you start to see Apple
getting behind some of this you know
recently they famously put up on their
fan page you know that here's some games
you pay once yeah and you actually might
be excited to keep playing it's copy hey
to play you might a brand-new concept
but yeah but I mean I think I think
that's ultimately good because you know
we you know we definitely cover and
we've actually it's interesting
sometimes in the past we've had people
complain because we famously mahasti had
a sponsor talk called safely monetizing
teens oh wow wow there's a title and and
it was and what actually taught us is
that we should screen the talks even
scream the titles of it yeah sponsor
talks because ultimately that was
something that someone actually you know
very clearly what marked is the sponsor
page have yeah but it still reflect to
cut pad and shitty see that we allowed
it to it so it's all a learning process
exactly so so so we note about that even
even even this year you know there are
talks talking about you know the big
spenders the whales in in in in in free
to play and and that's one that's one
whole area but on the other end we have
a bunch of stuff about indeed these
ports and v are so so we have we have
stuff stuff for everyone to get excited
about we also have stuff everyone to get
angry about was there any headline that
you got that you remember you were like
oh no no we can't do that well what what
like one particular talk title well well
it was that one from last year after I
was there anything like old we since
we're vetoing this year did anything
come up in your like no actually and the
funny thing about that was that there
were a couple of things about that talk
firstly some p some people went to went
to check it out and they found it was
actually a very sensible anodyne
practical talk yeah it's just you know
the concept to internet outrage you know
you can get quite excited about it but
it was actually a pretty pretty sad to
talk about you know there's all kinds of
laws about that it turns out this copper
laws about what you're meant to all
right yeah yeah these laws on us called
CIP PA which are about how you how you
meant to target people are under 14 so
it was it was about that but of course
it's a fine TT cedarwood to be like if
there was ever a conference like I
remember always wanted to go to e3 for
years and years and years being in
Ireland and then like GDC always seem
like an interesting thing as well but
for all the conference ever been to GDC
is the one that I
come away with with just feeling like so
humbled about how [ __ ] little I know
about games development i remember
watching this talk last year from the
guy from twin beard you made frog
fractions yeah it was basically did an
entire talk about how to like up this
case your game to the public how to hide
your game from the public and have frog
fractions to it's been kick-started
probably the best Kickstarter video I've
ever seen and still nobody knows if it's
out yes if it is like has he hidden it
in something and it was an entire talk
about how to hide your game and it's
such a such a crazy concept that you
never think of it wouldn't grab a
headline on gang spotter or another game
site but it was just such a like
interesting insight into the brain of
creators yeah there's a really easy
tarik star for the show you know we
actually have a talk this year in the
main conference in design about how 19th
century board games can confluent
today's video game designer why not like
yeah and you know and and and I will say
you know we try and go the majority of
our talks are quite practical we have a
lot you know as your viewers might know
we have a lot of very practical talks
about you know engines and like actually
my favorite practical talk from the
issue is there's a talk about how they
kept the wildlife stuck to the ground in
FarCry 4 because it turns out that's
actually a really difficult technical
from right because all these mountain
lions clearly can't be floating like 10
foot ok yeah yeah and so there's an
entire to 60 minutes on how they kept
the wild race to the ground of and if
you're making a game with a ton of
characters and a ton of mountains that's
absolutely a difficult thing but that's
the kind of thing the average person
would just not not think of it wow
that's a bog I would have liked to have
seen an assassin's creed actor simon
thank you so much for coming in and
talking to us at best of luck next week
and of course a bunch of news from GDC
and also a bunch of talks and of course
the live stream of the GDC choice awards
and the IGF awards will be on gamespot
com next week thank you so much for
watching this week's episode the lobby
please let us know what you think in the
comments below we'll be back next week
of course this GV see it's just down the
road so gonna have a bunch of developers
on the couch showing off their wares and
telling us everything that's going on
down at the conference for those of you
who can't make it into town so we'll see
you then enjoy vici gaming i will see
you on the other side adios
you